[Música]
desde que era pequeña mis papás que
hicieron que tuviera una educación
incluyente así que cada que salía del
colegio la buseta no me llevaba directo
al colegio al colegio sino que me dejaba
en una fundación donde enseñaban música
a niños jóvenes y adultos con
discapacidad intelectual yo interpretaba
la flauta junto a maravillosos artistas
que interpretaban la marimba que
interpretaba en la tambora la guitarra y
un sinfín de instrumentos esto me
permitió ver y más importante escuchar
la posibilidad de cada uno de ellos
este proceso me impactó tanto que al
iniciar mi carrera en diseño de
comunicación visual logré ver la
posibilidad de las metodologías de
diseño para la expresión de las personas
así que en el 2016 cuando me gradué de
mi carrera
me vinculé a esa fundación a la que
pertenecía cuando era pequeña
actualmente trabajamos por lograr la
inclusión y la integración de las
personas con discapacidad intelectual
mediante el arte y el diseño
pero
cada que contaba esta historia como lo
acabo de hacer siempre recibía las
mismas preguntas
y cómo es trabajar con un chico con
trastornos del espectro autista no se
pegan contra las paredes y cómo es
trabajar con un niño con síndrome de
dawn se entienden
y no te da miedo
usted es quien me dirían si yo les pido
que me hablen sobre una persona con
discapacidad
les voy a presentar a daniel daniel es
uno de mis estudiantes en el colectivo
creativo daniel siempre llega a mi
oficina con dos cámaras fotográficas en
cada uno de sus bolsillos esto por si
aún es del acaba la batería tiene la
otra para continuar daniel un día entró
a mi oficina y me pidió que nos
tomáramos una foto que le tomaremos una
foto al escritorio que nos tomáramos una
foto juntos que le tomáramos una foto
del cielo y pensé que daniel nos quería
decidir o contar algo y repensar
qué interesante sería si le damos una
cámara fotográfica a cada chico con
trastorno del espectro autista y dejamos
que sean ellos mismos quienes nos
cuenten y retrat en su entorno
así iniciamos escucha lo que veo en
conjunto con pedagogos terapeutas
psicólogos
empezamos la sensibilización frente al
uso de la cámara fotográfica porque mi
intención siempre en estos procesos
además de un resultado y una experiencia
impactante es que haya un proceso de
enseñanza-aprendizaje detrás en este
caso el uso de la cámara fotográfica
como método para la comunicación
y empezamos la aventura nos fuimos para
el museo de la tertulia y el parque de
los solados libremente cada uno de los
artistas empezó a retratar su entorno
espacios llamativos formas y colores
pues mi intención no era decirles a que
debían tomarle una foto sino qué tal si
nosotros escuchamos atentamente que nos
quieren decir ellos
cuando tuve la oportunidad de abrir las
más de 100 fotos en mi computador quedé
maravillada la cantidad de historias que
estaba presenciando ahora les voy a
mostrar algunas de las fotografías de
tres de estos artistas y como el
silencio hace parte fundamental de
escuchar escuchamos las fotos
y esque
cuando me preguntaban que si se pegaban
que si entendían que si no me daba miedo
es porque hay un estigma la
estigmatización la vio en las personas
con discapacidad intelectual con
problemas mentales con discapacidad
física o si no encajas en los
estereotipos de belleza serás
estigmatizado y si encajas también y
esto repercute en el bienestar y la
calidad de vida de las personas ya que
no permite su desarrollo no permite su
estabilidad emocional y no permite
tampoco su interacción social cuando nos
permitimos escuchar a las personas
logramos realmente reconocer en ellos
sus habilidades su pasión y su enfoque y
así sus vivencias del mundo
cuando hicimos la apertura de escucha lo
que veo en una biblioteca de cali
participaron más de 200 personas que muy
atentos a escuchar podían ver las
historias que les quería contar cada uno
de los artistas los artistas se fueron
con su traje y muy felices estuvieron
firmando autógrafos narrando su historia
mediante la fotografía permitiendo así
que cada uno de los asistentes que ha
estado en escuchar lo que veo ya sean
congresos
museos en universidades en ambientes
académicos permita quitarse la etiqueta
y pueda ver realmente a las personas y
su esencia cuando
terminamos escuchar lo que veo uno de
los artistas siempre se acercaba manuel
y me decía cuando volveríamos al museo
cuando íbamos a ir otra vez a tomar una
foto al parque de los solados lo que
hicimos fue entregarle una cámara
fotográfica y en el colectivo creativo
trabajamos todos los días porque el siga
potenciando su habilidad participamos en
concursos y él ahora se empoderó de la
fotografía si yo
les voy esto demuestra primero que todo
que no hay limitaciones hay diferentes
formas de ver el mundo
si yo les voy a hablar de danielle
prefiero que ustedes vayan lo conozcan y
reconozcan en él su pasión su entusiasmo
y su carisma
hoy quiero invitarlos a poder ver la
posibilidad que hay detrás de entender
la capacidad de todos qué tal si desde
diferentes prácticas logramos reducir el
estigma permitiendo así escuchar las
vivencias de las personas cómo podemos
lograr la apertura de espacios de
inclusión y de integración en la
comunidad hoy quiero invitarlos a que
valoren y acogen la diferencia hoy
quiero invitarlos a escuchar lo que
vemos
[Aplausos]